in your opinions do you think that the
housing bubble would have been prevented
if maybe 30 years ago this sort of it
seems like now there's more of a trend
with tiny homes had been adopted and
maybe some of these codes were more
lacks or just more friendly to tiny
homes rather than what's happened people
getting in over their head or is that
mentality that people kind of always
want what they can't have in place and
so well in my opinion I guess um I kind
of think that the housing crisis was
necessary to change the culture around
specific rock consumption but
specifically around the home sizes that
we choose to you know the structure
choose to live in because I think that
you know is this upward trend and I
didn't see that really changing unless
stores like some sort of that was
outside you know force because it really
was this culture of you know if there's
the keeping up with the Joneses and then
the the I mean I think it's all rooted
in this this concept of American dream
you know of this is what it's like to be
successful in America it's to have a you
know the certain size house and a
certain kind of job and it's a status
thing and and I think until you know
that came up against the hard reality of
you know housing crisis it's like that
would that probably wouldn't have
changed yeah I think also kind of just
the in rat the rise and more
environmental awareness you know in the
last year's as well and people kind of
realizing that we have to you know one
of the interviews that we interview a
few days ago she was talking about how I
really do have to think of growth and
consuming differently you know we can't
just keep producing new things to
consume and then throwing them away it's
just not you know feasible and that we
have to think about you know consuming
things that are used and you know
reusing things and being a little bit
smarter about the way that we consume in
the way that we build and I think that's
also part of the tiny house movement so
I mean I think it's a combination of of
the recession and you know the economic
crash that happened and then also kind
of a growing environmental awareness and
then I mean I think also with younger
generations there has been a
reevaluation of the American dream just
in terms of most people I know don't
want to just get a job they don't like
to support a lifestyle that they like
most people that I know are want to have
the flexibility to figure out what
lifestyle fits the life that they want
and so it's less of like a you know
mortgage marriage car in the garage kind
of thing and more flexible
you